a long time ago a group of deadly
mercenaries were abducted from Earth and
hibernated in space for 100 years then
one day they were dropped from a
spaceship and finally let free the movie
opens up with an armed officer Royce
falling from the spaceship during his
Free Fall he gains Consciousness and
somehow manages to open his parachute
after landing in a forest he starts
inspecting the place to check if anyone
else is present just then a Mexican drug
cartel enforcer cucio also lands there
in the same manner as soon as he
landscuccio points his gun at Royce and
threatens to shoot him both of them are
confused on how they got there and
things get heated between them while the
two are arguing another human falls from
the sky but without his parachute as a
result he dies on the spot Royce and
cucio are taken aback by the incident
but suddenly someone opens fire at them
they somehow scramble to safety and
devise a plan to round up the attacker
fortunately the plan works and Royce is
able to hold off the man at gunpoint
once interrogated he finds out that the
man is a Spetsnaz soldier named Nikolai
who was also brought to the forest in
the same manner the three then decide to
put their differences aside and work
together to find a way to escape the
forest after walking for some time the
three men come across a dangerous
looking lady pointing a sniper at them
she is Isabelle an IDF sniper At first
she threatens to shoot the men one by
one but when Royce assures her that they
are all on the same page she lowers her
weapon shortly after Isabelle reveals
that she has ventured through a lot of
forests in her lifetime but has never
come across this one she also mentions
that she noticed some other people in
the sky with parachutes hearing this the
group becomes hopeful of finding an
Escape Route and heads in the said
Direction on their way they noticed two
men fighting mercilessly they are
mumbassa an Ruf officer from Sierra
Leone and stance a death row inmate from
the states however as soon as they see
Royce in the group they stop after a
while the group of six start walking
through the forest and hear some screams
surprisingly a normal looking guy is
hang hanging upside down from the branch
of a tree this indicates that he doesn't
have any experience in combat Royce
being the alpha of the group which is
saying a lot since he's hanging out with
blade and machete shoots the branch down
and rescues the man following this the
man introduces himself as Dr Edwin a
famous physician from California he also
tells them that the last thing he
remembers is leaving his house for work
none of them are aware of their location
or how they got there soon Royce takes
command of the group but offers little
information about himself because of
this Isabelle suspects that he is a
mercenary and a former member of the
black ops military after a while as the
group continues walking Royce theorizes
that they have been transported to the
forest for a specific reason since they
are all assassins except for Edwin in
the next scene the group discovers empty
cages and a plant that contains
neurotoxin Nikolai is fascinated by the
plant but as he is about to touch it Dr
Edwin stops him and explains about how
the plant can paralyze someone within
seconds he then removes a part of the
plants with a tiny scalpel for further
study together they continue their
journey and add another person to their
group a Yakuza member Hanzo who prefers
to remain silent later that day Isabelle
calls Royce and shows him that the
magnetic compass is not working here in
turn Royce also reveals that since the
moment they arrived the sun hasn't
changed its position in the sky this
indicates that the forest is unlike any
ordinary one after a while as the group
continues searching through the forest
Mombasa accidentally steps on a trap to
their bad luck it is not just one trap
but a series of deadly traps numerous
logs sharp objects and even spikes are
launched to the ground in a matter of
seconds as everyone scrambles to safety
Isabelle slips and nearly falls into a
pit containing pointed sticks luckily
Royce comes to a rescue and pulls her
out once the danger is averted the group
gathers around and discusses their next
strategy calculating the size and weight
of the traps Royce concludes that it was
not for humans but for something much
bigger and more dangerous nearby they
also find the rotting corpse of a U.S
Special forces officer when Nikolai goes
through his pocket he finds a document
which states that the soldier was
supposed to be deployed in Afghanistan
then Royce examines the corpse and
presumes that the giant creature for
which the traps were said might have
killed the soldier during their
discussion someone or something can be
seen keeping an eye on them through
thermal vision shortly after the group
continues moving forward and finally
reaches the end of the hill to their
horror they realize they are not on
Earth because the sky there seems
different now everything that was
thought to be strange starts making
sense looking at the alien Sky Royce
tells everyone that they need to come up
with a solid plan to return home however
just as the group enters the forest
again they are attacked by a pack of
alien dogs these dogs are extremely
large in size and move with tremendous
speed everyone takes out their guns and
starts shooting at the dogs together
they manage to kill most of them but one
survives and starts marching towards
Isabel she tries to shoot it with her
sniper but unfortunately it jams she
then reaches for her revolver instead
and Fires at the dog multiple times but
to no avail now with death imminent
Isabelle decides to commit the
unthinkable but suddenly a bell rings
and the alien dog returns back soon the
whole group gathers at a place and Royce
tells everyone that they are being
hunted he also asks the group members to
reload their weapons because the attacks
are unpredictable and because not
reloading is stupid but at the same time
Mombasa realizes that cucio is missing
worried they start looking for him and
eventually find him wounded and asking
for help for some reason he doesn't face
the group and keeps on saying help me in
a weird manner Isabel being the most
sympathetic person in the group decides
to help him but Royce stops her claiming
that it's a trap he then throws a stone
near cuccio to prove his point lo and
behold the rock activates a trap and as
a result the group decides to leave
cuccio as he is already doomed before
leaving Isabelle puts him out of his
misery with her sniper rifle but
strangely even after he's dead his voice
crying for hell can be heard now the
group led by Royce follows the alien
dog's Footprints and reaches a hunting
camp there they notice a strange
creature that has been tied up as the
group continues inspecting the place
four larger creatures arrive there and
brutally Gore mumbassa to death luckily
the remainder of the gang manages to
flee and jump into a river here we are
introduced to the Predators the real
Kings of the Jungle altogether there are
four Predators the classic the tracker
the falconer and the Berserker they are
large in size and use advanced
technology to locate their prey and keep
themselves hidden meanwhile the group
reaches a Shore and Isabelle yells at
Royce for using Mombasa as bait just to
catch a glimpse of the Predators Royce
defends himself by saying that he just
wanted to see and collect more
information about the creatures that
they're fighting against he then asks
Isabel to tell everyone what she knows
about the aliens initially Isabelle is
hesitant but when the group stares at
her in Anger she finally reveals that
she has heard of these creatures before
long ago in the forests of Guatemala a
team of special forces were sent out for
a regular drill but only one came out
alive from his report everyone got to
know about Bigfoot I mean about a deadly
alien creature that could hide itself
and shoot lasers from its eyes after the
Revelation Royce Riles up the group and
asks them to assist him in finishing off
the predators in the next scene the
group carries out their plan and makes
Edwin run into the forest as bathe as
expected one of the Predators the
classic catches wind of this and starts
following Edwin it appears as if the
classic is the dumbest out of all four
Predators as it fails to notice the
group waiting to shoot from a distance
the plan works and just as the classic
is about to launch towards Edwin
Isabelle takes a clean shot and kills
the Predator however when the group
approaches the corpse they realize that
Isabel had actually missed her shot
suddenly a human wearing an advanced
alien suit appears in front of them and
introduces himself as Noland he reveals
that he has been evading the Predators
and successfully living in the forest
for years following the introductions
Noland takes the group to his place
which seems to be a dilapidated
spaceship of some sort inside he tells
everyone that the Predators are of two
types small and large scientific he also
mentions that the Predators gather
Warriors and deadly animals from other
worlds and bring them to this planet
their main objective is to hunt and
improve their killing abilities just
like video games that's not why I play
video games Noland additionally Nolan
claims that the two sets of predators
have been at War for centuries hearing
this Royce comes up with a plan he wants
to liberate the smaller Predator from
the camp team up with it and gain access
to its spaceship so that he can return
back to Earth at night while the entire
group is resting Nolan secretly locks
the door from outside and starts
suffocating them with smoke it turns out
that he is a scavenger and his only
intention was to lure the group and
steal their weapons inside the group
tries their best to open the door but
it's locked tightly now with time
running out Royce makes a risky decision
and fires an explosive at the door his
plan was to attract the Predators and it
works in no time the Predators invade
The Hideout the tracker comes across
Noland and immediately rips him to
pieces then it marches towards the
remaining group and even breaks the door
but surprisingly instead of killing them
straight away the tracker lets them flee
as if it's toying with them during the
chase everyone else but Nikolai manages
to escape the tracker catches him and
stabs him brutally but before dying
Nikolai detonates a bomb and blows both
of them to Smithereens meanwhile the
rest of the group reaches outside and
hears the explosion this gives them some
momentary relief but suddenly the
Berserker arrives there realizing that
their death is imminent this time stanz
makes the ultimate sacrifice and holds
the Predator until his friends can run
away sadly his heroism turns into
despair as the Berserker rips out his
spine and kills him instantly with
Stan's death only four members in the
group are remaining after they reach a
field the Yakuza Hanzo who has been
quiet for the entire Journey senses
something and instructs the rest of the
group to leave suddenly the falconer
approaches him slowly Hanzo taken a
samurai sword from Nolan's base so he
decides to use this stereotype for his
final dance surprisingly despite having
Advanced lasers and other Weaponry the
falconer respects hanzo's courage and
decides to fight in Fair combat soon the
battle begins and both Warriors go
hammer and tongs at each other It
ultimately ends when Hanzo slices off
the falconer however seconds later he
also succumbs to his injuries elsewhere
as the remaining three are heading
towards the camp Edwin gets injured by a
trap he tries to get up but fails
realizing that he has become a liability
Roy suggests Isabel leave him there but
the latter refuses as a result Royce
leaves the two of them and continues the
journey on his own sadly when Isabel is
helping the injured Edwin they get
caught in a net trap meanwhile Royce
reaches the hunting camp and confronts
the small Predator that is being held
captive there he talks to the predator
in human language and makes a deal which
will benefit them both Royce will
release the predator and in turn it will
help him escape the planet surprisingly
the predator obliges and as soon as it
is released it activates a nearby
spaceship for Royce suddenly the large
final Predator which also happens to be
the most powerful one the Berserker
arrives there the two species of
predators then start fighting and as
expected the Berserker kills the smaller
one after the victory the Berserker also
blows up the spaceship that was about to
leave for Earth seemingly killing Royce
meanwhile Edwin and Isabelle managed to
escape the net and reach a bit further
surprisingly Edwin takes out the
poisonous scalpel from before and makes
a cut on Isabelle's throat then he
starts revealing everything he is not a
normal person after all in fact he is
the worst out of the eight selected
people back on Earth he murdered several
people and was deemed a psycho Edwin
further mentions that now he has started
liking this world and wants to live here
permanently even if Eric is stoned
that's a dumbass plan as Isabel hears
all of this she starts getting Paralyzed
by the neurotoxin just then Royce shows
up and approaches the duo it turns out
that he missed the spaceship he
immediately carries Isabelle away
believing that the Predator attacked her
shortly after as he is tending to her
wounds Edwin attempts to attack him from
behind but Royce counters and stabs The
Lunatic with his own scalpel then he
installs some explosives inside a
paralyzed Edwin and uses him as bait to
lure the remaining Predator as soon as
the Berserker attacks Edwin a huge
explosion occurs but it is still
insufficient to eliminate it luckily
Royce is prepared for this situation he
knows that the Predators locate their
prey with thermal vision so he covers
his body with mud and also lights fire
everywhere the plan seems to work at
first and the Berserker gets confused
but soon it tracks Royce's heartbeat and
attacks him in the meantime Isabel
starts regaining Consciousness and uses
every ounce of her strength to get to
her sniper just when the Berserker is
about to kill Royce she shoots it in the
shoulder taking advantage of the
opportunity Royce gets up and uses a
makeshift ax to decapitate the Berserker
and end the madness once and for all the
movie ends as Isabelle and Royce wonder
how they can turn back to the Earth
spoilers ahead they can't subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching